إذا كنت في المعارضة اللبنانية
فهذه هي الديمقراطية في العمل على بعد
30 أو 40 ياردة أسفل الشارع
المحصن
هناك الطوق الخارجي للبرلمان اللبناني ،
فالمتظاهرون قد ماتوا تمامًا
وقد أخبروني
عن الدخول إلى المزيد والمزيد من
المباني الحكومية  في محاولة لإثبات
أن الحكومة نفسها
هي في الحقيقة كاميرا ، إنها ميؤوس
منها وهي نوع من المزاح
مع استمرار التنظيف بعد
أن يعتقد أن آلاف الأطنان من الأسمدة قد فجرت
ودمرت أجزاء من
نشطاء بيروت ، يصرون على أن
النظام الطائفي في لبنان  أدى الفساد والإهمال في سياسات الأسرة الحاكمة
إلى الانفجار ، سنذهب إلى
البرلمان ، وسنذهب إلى منازلهم
، وسنذهب
إلى كل مكان لإنزالهم
، وسيذهبون إلى مكان
لن يكون بمقدورهم الذهاب إليه  شوارع من
أي وقت مضى القتلى
هو شيء كبير بالنسبة لنا
برلمان لبنان حيث يتقاسم 128 مقعدا
بين المسيحيين السنة والشيعة
بموجب قانون الانتخاب التالي.  تم حل الحرب الأهلية
قبل 30 عامًا قبل
إجراء انتخابات جديدة ،
لكن وليد جيم بلات زعيم
الدرو الذي ورث دوره عن
والده واستفاد من
النظام الحالي ،
متشائم من أنه حتى الانتخابات المبكرة
ستحدث التغيير
عندما أرى المحتجين
ثوري
عندما رأيتهم وأراهم
بالأمس ويريدون تغيير لبنان
يريدون لبنان الجديد لكن
معوقات التغيير في الحضر
وفي هذه النقطة بالتحديد تحالف
الأقليات
والقانون الانتخابي لأنك لا تستطيع
تغيير لبنان من
خلال دعنا نقول  جيش من
المستحيل
بالقرب من بؤرة تفجير يوم الثلاثاء
مقر الحزب القطري
في حالة خراب ، إنه حزب ماروني مسيحي إلى حد كبير
قتل أمينه العام في
الانفجار ،
ولا تزال بصمته الدموية التي لا تزال
مرئية حفيد مؤسس الحزب
ونجل رئيس سابق.
ابن شقيق رئيس آخر
قتل سامي جمال يدعم
احتجاجات الشوارع نحن  جميعهم من
عائلات كانت
جزءًا من ندوة الويب القديمة ، هذا هو
أه كيف أننا الجيل الجديد
لم نأت
من العدم ومن واجبنا أن
نقوم
بثورتنا الخاصة بنا كل فرد في مجتمعه
والمكان الذي  إنه موجود في ساحة الشهداء ، ومن بين
المتظاهرين
الآن قائد الكوماندوز اللبناني السابق
العقيد جورج نادار
الذي يريد أن يرى الحرس القديم يكتسح
بالكامل في
تلك الليلة ، كانت الاحتجاجات هي التي
جرفت في النهاية
ولكن ليس لفترة طويلة لديهم خطط
لتسخير الغضب العام بسبب  بيروت
تنفجر
إلى غضب ثوري أقوى
سام كيلي سي إن بيروت